COLT MCANLIS: If you've ever
painted a room or a house,
you know that it takes a lot of
work to color in those walls,
and if you need to
repaint it again,
you've wasted a ton of work
doing it the first time.
This same concept of wasting
effort to paint something
can also attribute to
performance problems
in your applications.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and at the intersection
of performance and design lies
a common performance problem--
overdraw.
Overdraw is a term
used to describe
how many times a
pixel on the screen
has been redrawn
in a single frame.
For example, if we have a
bunch of stacked UI cards,
all the cards in the upper part
of the stack closer to the user
hide large portions of the
cards hidden underneath,
meaning that we'll need to
spend time drawing those cards,
which are mostly invisible.
This is a large problem
because each time we're
rendering pixels that don't
contribute to the final scene,
we're effectively
wasting GPU performance.
And with modern layouts,
it's easy to fall into a trap
where we're stacking
and layering
views to give us
beautiful design,
but also creating
this same problem.
To maximize the performance
of your application,
you'll want to
minimize overdraw.
And thankfully, it's really easy
to see the impact of overdraw
on your applications right
on the Android device.
Simply go into Developer
Mode and then turn
on Show GPU Overdraw flag.
Now, don't be alarmed
while your phone
turns into some sort of
weird visual awesomeness.
This is normal.
What's occurring is
that Android is now
showing overdraw
amounts on your screen
through tinting pixels
a different color.
If you've only rendered
a pixel one time,
you should see it in its
true color with no tint.
However, as the overdraw
increases, so do the colors.
1x overdraw, for
example, is tinted blue,
meaning that you've now redrawn
this pixel one extra time.
And of course, 2x,
3x, and 4x overdraw
follow the same pattern.
The goal of your application is
to reduce as much overdraw as
possible, which will move you
from seeing lots of deep red
down to seeing lots more blues.
Now, while overdraw
will organically
come from just how your
views overlap each other,
a more common problem
for folks to be aware of
is lots of unneeded
overlapping backgrounds,
for example, having
an activity background
which gets overdrawn
with a layout, which
has a series of children
who all have backgrounds.
Don't forget the text
boxes, and of course
the titles, and
those backgrounds
as well, and of course, there's
the avatar backgrounds and then
the avatars themselves.
You can quickly see how
this can get out of hand.
Doing something as simple as
removing unneeded backgrounds
can take your application from
having a horde of angry red
to a calming sea of blue, which
is why you need to check out
the rest of our Android
Performance Patterns content
for other ways to
improve performance,
and don't forget to join our
Google+ community for more
excellent info as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]